at the world economic forum on africa in
Dar es Salaam Tanzania we're setting up
a Davos debates video corner here
participants including presidents and
business leaders will respond for your
video to your questions and ideas on the
region's most pressing challenges so
what is your vision for Africa and what
opportunities and barriers does Africa
face what questions do you have for the
leaders who will gather in Dar es Salaam
send your ideas and questions via video
or text to youtube.com slash Davos you
can also vote on your favorite
contributions from others the
contributions with the highest number of
votes will be put to the leaders at the
Davos debates corner giving direct
access to some of the most powerful and
influential people in the world the best
entries may also be shown at the meeting
tell us what you think go to youtube.com
slash Davos to join the conversation